KNOW ABOUT THAT UNMASKING IN
THAT JANUARY FOR THE MEETING
QUESTION >> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: RIGHT QUESTIONS,
THANK YOU SARAH.
A BREAKING DEVELOPMENT TONIGHT.
SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING
FOR SOME TIME.
RIC GRENELL, WE NOW HAVE
EVIDENCE JOHN BRENNAN ACTUALLY
HAD INTELLIGENCE THAT THE
RUSSIANS WANTED HILLARY TO WIN.
REMEMBER "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FINALLY SAID OH, IT WAS LIKELY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM THE
GET-GO.
BUT THAT’S IN THESE NEWLY
RELEASED HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATIONS.
AND TRANSCRIPTS.
WE LEARNED THAT HE SAID HE,
HILLARY KNEW WE WERE PLAYING THE
RUSSIANS.
I BET IT WAS COMING UP FROM
RUSSIA.
BUCKLE UP, MUCH MORE TO COME.
ESPECIALLY NOW AS THE COMMITTEE
IS PREPARED TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS
TO DEEP STATE BAD ACTORS IF THEY
REFUSED TO COMPLY.
AND SPECIFICALLY THE COMMITTEE
IS NOW SEEKING MORE ANSWERS AS
IT RELATES TO THAT INFAMOUS
JANUARY 5TH 2017 DISCUSSION
BETWEEN YATES AND BRENNAN AND
KLAPPER AND CALL CALL.
BY THE WAY, THE JUDGE’S DECISION
TO POSTPONE THE RULING IN THE
FLYNN CASE IS ALSO ON THE AGENDA
AGENDA.
WE HAVE CHAIRMAN, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
AT THAT FEBRUARY 5TH MEETING IS
IMPORTANT.
THE UNMASKING IS IMPORTANT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHY THEY WERE
UNMASKING.
I THOUGHT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
PRACTICE, SENATOR?
>> YEAH, THE QUESTION FOR US AS
A CONGRESS IS DID THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION USE UNMASKING AS
A POLITICAL WEAPON?
THAT’S THE QUESTION THAT I WANT
TO ANSWER.
THE JANUARY 5TH MEETING, I’M
DYING TO KNOW HOW EXACTLY WHY
SALLY YATES DID NOT KNOW ABOUT
THE INVESTIGATION.
BUT PRESIDENT OBAMA DID.
I WOULD URGE RIC GRENELL, WHO
HAS DONE A TERRIFIC JOB, TO
RELEASE THE NAMES OF THE PEOPLE
WHO MADE THE REQUEST.
LET ME GO BACK TO SOMETHING YOU
MENTIONED TO SARAH.
TREY GOWDY ASKED SOME OF THE
POWERS, DID YOU MAKE A REQUEST
TO UNMASKED CITIZENS AND HE SAID
"I MADE NO WHERE NEAR THIS OF
REQUESTS."
BUT THE NSA AND THEIR FILES HAVE
300, ALMOST 300 REQUEST BEING
MADE BY AT SAMANTHA POWERS.
IF SHE DIDN’T DO IT, WHO DID.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN THAT SALLY
YATES AND MICHAEL CALL EXPRESSED
>> IT MEANS THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION INTENTIONALLY
UNMASKED A CONVERSATION WITH THE
INCOMING NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT IS STUNNING.
IF I EVER FIND THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS
UNMASKING MY PHONE CALLS WITH
FOREIGN LEADERS, OR I DISCUSS
FOREIGN POLICIES BEING DONE IN
THE UNITED STATES, HEADS WILL
ROLL.
I FIND IT UNBELIEVABLE THAT THE
OUTGOING ADMINISTRATION IS
SURVEILLING THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY WRONG.
AT THE MINIMUM, UNETHICAL.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
REALIZATION NOW THAT HILLARY --
YOU HAVE ONE GUY THAT WHO HAS
GIVEN THE BILLS FROM FUSION GPS
TO PAY FOR THE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
AND TO SAY THAT IN FACT YEAH,
HILLARY KIND OF KNEW.
WE ALL KNEW THAT WE WERE PAYING
FOR OFF RESEARCH.
AND SOME OF IT WAS FROM RUSSIA.
IN THE END, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ACTUALLY GOT SOMETHING RIGHT.
TOILET PAPER TIMES.
AND THAT IS THEY FIGURED OUT IT
WAS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION BID
WHICH MEANS IT CAME FROM THE
RUSSIANS.
THE BAD INTEL ON TRUMPET AND THE
RESEARCH WAS DESIGNED TO HELP
HILLARY, NOT TO TRUMP.
>> YEAH, THE DOCUMENT WAS USED
TO GET A WARRANT.
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS IS NOT A DISTRACTION, THIS
IS UNDERMINING OF THE LAW.
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IT.
>> FIRST WEEK IN JUNE.
UNLESS THE JUDGE SCREWS
EVERYTHING UP BY NOT ISSUING A
RULING.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THE JUDGE IS
CONFLICTED ABOUT WHAT TO DO HERE
HERE.
DISMISS THE CASE.
>> Sean: DISMISSED THE CASE.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED THAT THE
OFFICE OF DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, THAT IN FACT WILL